este es nuestro controlador del motor l
298 que vamos a usar para controlar los
motores de nuestra bici bot vamos a
controlar la rapidez y dirección de los
motores de la secadora de cabello usando
esto también nos va a permitir cambiar
el alto voltaje y corriente que
necesitamos para el motor por una
corriente y voltaje bajos que
necesitamos para nuestro arduino que es
nuestro microcontrolador el arduino
tiene muchos paneles en donde podemos
conectar el controlador del motor para
obviamente controlar el motor y también
tiene un puerto usb que nos permite
conectarlo a la computadora para
programarlo y decirle que hacer al
controlador del motor
este es el motor que vamos a usar es el
motor de una secadora de cabello y lo
vamos a usar como una de las ruedas de
nuestra bici bota para hacer que se
mueva como nosotros queramos el
controlador del motor nos permite
controlar dos de estos motores este es
una de las razones por la que elegimos
este controlador del motor
la otra razón es porque viene como un
paquete para armas
para comenzar necesitamos soldadura con
núcleo de resina 60-40 el núcleo de
resina hace que la soldadura se adhiera
mejor lo primero que vamos a hacer es
seleccionar las resistencias para el
circuito l 298 estas resistencias son de
47 kilos 11 y pueden saber que son de 47
kilos porque como todas las resistencias
tienen franjas con código de colores que
indican cuál es su nivel de resistencia
el código de colores de estas
resistencias en particular son amarillo
naranja púrpura y dorado colocamos las
resistencias les doblamos las patitas de
manera que la resistencia quede pegada a
la tarjeta y vamos a calentar la ruta de
soldadura donde se encuentran las
resistencias para que aquí fluya la
soldadura puede dejarnos un poco de
tiempo el que esto nos salga bien a la
primera pero el calentar la ruta de la
soldadura nos ayuda a que la soldadura
fluya y haga una buena conexión
nos aseguramos de que quede la soldadura
suficiente para rodear la conexión y que
ésta quede bien hecha a veces no es
sencillo dejar el punto de soldadura en
donde queremos pero lo vamos a lograr
algo importante es mantener limpia la
punta del cautín revisamos de nuevo las
conexiones para asegurarnos que sean
sólidas y que nuestros componentes se
encuentren en donde deben estar
vemos que la soldadura ha pasado al otro
lado y ha hecho una buena conexión en
cada una de las resistencias vamos a
cortar lo que sobra de las patitas y
para eso usamos nuestras pinzas de corte
y debemos cortarlas lo más cerca que
podamos de la tarjeta pero sin afectar
la conexión
ahora instalaremos nuestras otras dos
resistencias en esta ocasión vamos a ver
lo más rápido pues ya vieron cómo
conectamos las resistencias estas
resistencias son de 2.2 kilos y nos
sirven para proteger nuestras lámparas
leds indicadoras que pueden ver en la
parte de arriba de la pantalla el rojo y
el verde sabemos que las resistencias
son de 2.2 kilos porque su código de
colores es rojo rojo rojo y dorado
soldamos las patitas de las resistencias
que doblamos para mantener las
resistencias en su lugar estas
resistencias las colocamos verticalmente
a diferencia de las otras que colocamos
al principio ya que aquí tenemos menos
espacio
ahora vamos a instalar nuestros diodos
de retorno estos diodos van a proteger a
nuestro circuito de rebotes de corriente
que puedan tener nuestros motores estos
diodos son los mismos que usamos en un
rectificador de puente es importante
instalar los de una forma en particular
pueden ver que aquí hay un pequeño
cuadrado del lado derecho de la marca
del diodo y esto nos indica que debemos
alinear la franja plateada en el diodo
con esta marca así que la franja
plateada debe estar del lado del borde
exterior de la tarjeta de esta manera
nuestros diodos estarán en la posición
correcta
como saben los diodos funcionan como
válvulas que sólo permiten que la
electricidad fluya en una sola dirección
por lo que es importante instalar los
diodos de la manera correcta pueden ver
que los diodos no quedan totalmente
planos por lo que tomo mis pinzas de
nariz de aguja y los ayudo empujando el
resto del camino cada patita es
importante que queden planos todos los
componentes en la tarjeta ahora doblamos
las patitas de los diodos como lo
hicimos con las resistencias y nos
aseguramos de que queden bien alineados
y algo muy importante hay que evitar que
las patitas se toquen entre sí cuando
las estemos soldando verificamos que las
patitas estén separadas y que los diodos
queden planos sobre la tarjeta ya que
está todo bien los soldados en su lugar
y después colocaremos los otros 6 diodos
en su lugar
ya los tenemos colocados los soldados y
cortamos lo que sobra de las patitas
nuevamente tenemos que asegurarnos de
que no se toquen las rutas de soldadura
entre sí verificamos que todas las
conexiones sean sólidas y que los diodos
estén colocados en la orientación
adecuada aquí vemos que la soldadura
cubre bien cada una de las conexiones y
ninguna de estas conexiones se tocan
entre sí
ahora vamos a instalar un capacitor que
filtra altas frecuencias ese punto 1
micro farage y es bipolar lo que quiere
decir que lo podemos colocar en
cualquier dirección no es como los
diodos en que si importa el sentido en
el que los colocamos nuevamente doblamos
las patitas del capacitor y soldamos las
conexiones uniéndolos con las rutas de
soldadura aquí hay que cuidar de no
poner más soldadura porque las
conexiones están muy cercanas
finalmente cortamos los excesos ahora
vamos a instalar nuestros diodos
emisores de luz o leds
estos leds nos van a permitir ver en qué
dirección se mueven los motores o en qué
dirección fluye la corriente eléctrica
estos diodos indicadores son importantes
y también es importante que los
coloquemos de la forma correcta éstos
tienen una patita corta y una patita más
larga y la patita más corta tiene que
pasar a través de la ruta cuadrada el
diodo también tiene un lado plano el
cual se va a alinear con el lado plano
del diodo opuesto y es así como sabemos
que tenemos los diodos en la orientación
correcta también deben de quedar planos
sobre la tarjeta nos aseguramos de que
las patitas cortas queden una al lado de
la otra y que pasen a través de las
rutas cuadradas en el centro nuevamente
vamos a doblar todas las patitas para
mantener en su lugar a los diodos
mientras los soldados
ya que colocamos los diodos vamos a
conectar las tiras del zócalo adaptador
esto nos permite conectar cables más
fácilmente del arduino al controlador
del motor es un lugar en donde podemos
colocar los cables vamos a pegarlos para
mantenerlos en su lugar pues no son lo
suficientemente largos como para
doblarlos vamos a soldar los en las
rutas para que se queden firmemente en
su lugar ahora lo que sigue es conectar
nuestros bloques terminales los bloques
terminales nos permitirán conectar
nuestros motores directamente a nuestra
tarjeta de controlador l 298 y también
nos proporcionará un lugar para obtener
energía de la tarjeta hacia otros
componentes aquí estamos soldando
nuestros bloques terminales y nuestros
motores se van a cablear a los bloques
con dos terminales los pegamos
nuevamente para mantener los planos
contra la tarjeta ya que tienen la
tendencia de caerse de la tarjeta cuando
estamos soldando los en su lugar
este es un capacitor electrolítico y
vamos a instalar lo nuestro capacitor es
de 22 micro farts y 50 volts la ruta
redonda tiene que estar conectada a la
terminal positiva del capacitor que es
la de la patita más larga es un
capacitor polarizado
ahora tenemos nuestro regulador de 5
volts que nos permitirá obtener 5 volts
desde esta tarjeta lo colocamos y
soldamos sus conexiones este regulador
nos va a permitir dar energía a nuestro
arduino ahora tenemos nuestro circuito l
298 que es el circuito lógico de la
tarjeta y va a interpretar las señales
que mande o envíe el arduino y
proporcionará y controlará la energía
que llega a los motores de manera que el
l 298 es el alma y corazón de nuestro
controlador
solo podemos colocarlo en una posición y
al colocarlo debemos asegurarnos de que
todos los pines pasen por los conectores
y sobresalgan a la misma distancia para
ayudarme a hacer esto voy a poner algo
que me ayude a mantener elevada la
tarjeta del otro lado y así asegurarme
de que todos los pines sobresalen en la
misma distancia esto también hace que
sea más fácil soldar las calentamos las
rutas de soldadura para que nos queden
conexiones sólidas revisamos nuevamente
que no haya conexiones que puedan
provocar un cortocircuito que todas
nuestras conexiones luzcan sólidas y
correctas y parece que todo luce como
debe ser
podemos ver que ninguna soldadura toca
ninguna otra conexión en la parte de
arriba de la tarjeta vemos que todos los
elementos están planos contra la tarjeta
y están en los lugares correctos
ya tenemos listo nuestro controlador del
motor l 298 que nos permitirá controlar
los motores de nuestra beats y bot